Hi there, my name
is Katherine Kuan.
I'm the developer advocate on
the Google Developer Relations
team.
This video explains in
a little more detail
about the Valentine's
Day app that was first
introduced in the previous
video of the playlist.
Be sure to watch that one
first, if you haven't already.
So to pick up where
we left off, you
are customizing
this app containing
a list of coupons
for your Valentine.
We'll take a look,
now, under the hood,
and see how the views for
one coupon is constructed.
For each coupon, we start
with a relative layout.
Then we place an
ImageView inside of it,
which stretches the
whole width and height
of the relative layout.
You proceed by adding
a View at the bottom
with a slight
gradient, so the text
doesn't blend in with the photo.
On top of the gradient
overlay we then
add the title of the coupon.
The last View is a TextView
containing the description.
And there you have
the completed View.
We took the individual
coupon Views
and then laid them
out into a grid View.
The number of
columns in the grid
adapts based on screen
width for optimal viewing
of the app on all device sizes.
On phones like the Nexus 5,
it will be a single column
grid, which is
essentially a list.
And it's the same in both
portrait and landscape mode.
On tablets like Nexus 7, it
will be two columns in portrait
but three columns in landscape.
On tablets like Nexus 10,
we have a three column grid
in landscape and portrait mode.
For information on how the
resource folders are named
and set up, see
the provided link.
Keep in mind that
when you're displaying
all these images on such
high resolution screens,
you may consider
sizing down your images
so that when they're
all loaded up,
and the user is scrolling
through the list,
they don't run out of memory.
If you still have
performance issues,
then you can read more about
bitmaps with this link.
Now let's talk about how the
sharing part of the app works.
When the user taps on a coupon,
we build up a share intent
using the share compact class.
And the user can pick
which app to share, too.
The intent is composed of text
from the title and description
of the coupon, a content
URI that maps to the image,
and a type for the image.
You'll notice that we don't
pass the image file directly,
but rather a content
URI that the framework
uses to find the image.
In this case, the
Hangouts app, will
try to figure out
what the URI points to
and it will reach
our asset provider
class, which then translates
this URI into a file descriptor
with the right permissions
to access the image.
And that's how the
draft image ends up
in the Hangouts app within
the conversation thread.
The asset provider is an
example of a content provider.
Content providers can be
used to access a database,
or files like in our case.
This link shows
you where you can
get more info on
content providers.
So that's the overview
of everything.
Hope that helps, and good
luck with building your app.